Nunca olvidaré el sonido
de la voz de mi madre justo antes de quedarme dormida.
Y nunca olvidaré el sonido reconfortante del agua
goteando por una corriente.
Imaginen mi miedo, miedo puro,
cuando, a los 10 años,
me dijeron que iba a perder la audición.
Y durante los siguientes 5 años,
progresó hasta que me catalogaron como sorda profunda.
Pero yo creo que la pérdida de mi audición
fue uno de los mejores regalos que he recibido en mi vida.
Puedo experimentar el mundo de una manera única.
Creo que estas experiencias únicas
que tienen las personas con discapacidad
es lo que va a ayudarnos a hacer y diseñar un mundo mejor
para todos: para las personas con y sin discapacidad.
Yo solía ejercer de abogada de derechos de los discapacitados,
y pasé mucho tiempo centrada en hacer cumplir la ley,
asegurando de que se hicieran zonas adaptadas.
Y luego tuve que aprender rápidamente política internacional,
porque me pidieron que trabajara en la Convención de la ONU
para proteger a las personas con discapacidad.
Como líder de la ONG allí,
gasté la mayor parte de mi energía tratando de convencer a la gente
acerca de las capacidades de las personas con discapacidad.
Pero en algún lugar a lo largo del camino,
y tras muchas transiciones de carrera
con las que mis padres no estaban muy felices
(Risas)
me topé con una solución
que creo puede ser una herramienta aún más poderosa
para resolver algunos de los problemas mayores del mundo,
ya sea la discapacidad o no.
Y esa herramienta se llama pensamiento de diseño.
El pensamiento de diseño es un proceso de innovación y resolución de problemas.
Hay cinco pasos.
El primero: definición del problema
y comprensión de sus restricciones.
El segundo: la observación de las personas en situaciones de la vida real
y empatizar con ellas.
El tercero: la expresión de cientos de ideas, cuantas más mejor,
cuanto más primitivas, mejor.
El cuarto paso: creación de prototipos, recopilación de todo lo que se pueda,
lo que se pueda encontrar,
para imitar la solución, para probarlos
y para refinarlos.
Y, por último, la aplicación:
asegurando que la solución pensada es sostenible.
Warren Berger dice que el pensamiento de diseño nos enseña a mirar hacia los lados,
a replantear, a perfeccionar, a experimentar
y, probablemente lo más importante,
a hacer preguntas tontas.
Los pensadores de diseño creen que todo el mundo es creativo.
Creen en unir a las personas de múltiples disciplinas,
porque quieren compartir múltiples perspectivas,
juntarlas y al final fusionarlas
para formar algo nuevo.
El pensamiento de diseño es una herramienta tan exitosa y versátil
que se ha aplicado en casi todas las industrias.
Vi el potencial que tenía para los problemas que enfrenté,
así que decidí volver a la escuela
y obtener mi maestría en diseño social.
Este ve la forma de usar el diseño para crear un cambio positivo en el mundo.
Mientras estaba ahí,
me enamoré de la madera.
Pero lo que me di cuenta rápidamente
fue que me estaba perdiendo algo.
Cuando se trabaja con una herramienta,
justo antes de que esté a punto de volverse contra nosotros,
lo que significa que la herramienta nos viene de nuevo,
hace un sonido.
Y yo no podía escuchar ese sonido.
Así que pensé,
¿por qué no tratar de resolverlo?
Mi solución fue un par de gafas de seguridad
diseñadas para alertar al usuario visualmente
del cambio de tono en la herramienta,
antes de que el oído humano pueda percibirlo.
¿Por qué los diseñadores de herramientas no habían pensado en esto antes?
(Risas)
Dos razones: una, que era una principiante.
No estaba afectada por la experiencia o la sabiduría convencional.
La segunda: yo era sorda.
Mi experiencia única del mundo ayudó a contribuir a mi solución.
Y a medida que continué, seguí encontrando más y más soluciones
que se hicieron originalmente para las personas con discapacidad,
y que terminaron siendo recogidas,
adoptadas y asumidas por la corriente principal
con discapacidad o no.
Este es un pelador de patatas OXO.
Fue diseñado originalmente para las personas con artritis,
pero era tan cómodo, que a todo el mundo le encantó.
Los mensajes de texto fueron diseñados originalmente para las personas sordas.
Y como saben, a todo el mundo le encanta eso también.
(Risas)
Empecé a pensar:
¿Qué pasa si cambiamos nuestra manera de pensar?
¿Y si empezamos a diseñar para la incapacidad en primer lugar,
y no para la norma?
Como ven, al diseñar para la discapacidad en primer lugar,
a menudo nos tropezamos con soluciones que no solo son inclusivas,
sino también a menudo mejores que al diseñar para la norma.
Y esto me emociona,
porque significa que la energía que se necesita para tener en cuenta
a alguien con una discapacidad
se puede aprovechar, moldear y activar
como una fuerza para la creatividad y la innovación.
Esto nos lleva de la mentalidad de tratar de cambiar los corazones
y la idea de tolerancia basada en la carencia
a convertirnos en alquimistas,
los magos que este mundo necesita tan desesperadamente
para resolver algunos de sus problemas más graves.
También creo
que las personas con discapacidad tienen un gran potencial para ser diseñadores
dentro de este proceso de pensamiento de diseño.
Sin saberlo, desde una edad muy temprana,
he sido una pensadora de diseño, que perfeccionó sus habilidades.
Los pensadores de diseño son, por naturaleza, solucionadores de problemas.
Así que imaginen escuchar una conversación
y solo comprender el 50 % de lo que se dice.
No se puede pedir que repitan cada palabra.
Ellos también se sentirían frustrados con uno.
Así que sin darme cuenta,
mi solución era tomar el sonido sordo que oía,
que era el ritmo,
y convertirlo en un ritmo y colocarlo en los labios que leía.
Años después, alguien comentó que mi escritura tenía ritmo en ella.
Bueno, esto es porque experimento conversaciones como ritmos.
Y me volví muy, muy buena en fracasar.
(Risas)
Bastante literal.
En mi primer semestre de Español, obtuve una nota mala.
Pero aprendí que mejorando,
cambiando algunas cosas,
finalmente, lo lograba.
Del mismo modo, el pensamiento de diseño anima a la gente a fallar
y fallar a menudo,
porque, al final, uno tendrá éxito.
Muy pocas grandes innovaciones en este mundo
han venido de alguien que tuvo éxito en el primer intento.
También experimenté esta lección en los deportes.
Nunca olvidaré a mi entrenador diciendo a mi madre:
"Si ella no tuviera la pérdida de audición,
estaría en el equipo nacional".
Pero lo que ni mi entrenador ni yo sabíamos en ese momento,
era que mi pérdida de audición en realidad me ayudó a destacar en el deporte.
Cuando uno pierde la audición, no solo se puede adaptar el comportamiento,
sino también adaptar sus sentidos físicos.
Un ejemplo de esto
es que mi capacidad de atención visual aumentó.